let's get more now on those reports that
the author salman rushdie has been
attacked in western new york straight to
washington d.c and speak to dominic
wagon dominic what do we know
well
all that we know at the moment is these
reports from the associated press that
salman rushdie the indian-born british
novelist was on a stage in chatakwa
which is a leafy resort near lake erie
in upstate uh new york he was about to
address some kind of literary event at
the chatakwa institution where he was
attacked by a man who got onto the stage
and attacked him now initially the ap
said that he was stabbed they're now
saying that he was either either punched
or stabbed so we don't know exactly the
nature
of the attack or obviously of his
condition one tweet from the scene uh
purportedly from the scene saying that
he
walked off the stage with some
assistance so that sounding like it the
outcome of this attack isn't as serious
as it could have been but it's obviously
no confirmation of that there are a
couple of photographs of the attack
which show a crowd of onlookers and also
some law enforcement personnel that's
like crowding around a body on the floor
or trying to administer some kind of
help to somebody on the floor so i think
we're
still trying to work out what happened
and what state salman rushdie is in but
obviously attracting an enormous amount
of attention
this incident uh not least because of
rushdie's past he came to
fame in 1981 because of his book
midnight's children
a book about
indian independence and the partition
that in 1981 won a huge amount of
critical acclaim and won him the booker
prize and then uh eight years later
seven years later in 1988 he wrote the
satanic verses and the reaction to that
uh sparked one of the biggest religious
and freedom of speech controversies
really of our time saddam rushdie in
that book was accused of dealing with
the prophet muhammad the prophet
muhammad of the islam islamic religion
accused of treating him and depicting
him irreverent really irreverently and
that uh earned him the
anger particularly of ayatolly ayatollah
khamenei the leader of iran who issued a
fatwa effectively
a kind of international death sentence
on the writer and he went into hiding
for a number of years was only really
able to emerge from that safely when
mohammed qatami the the new leader of
iran president of iran eight years later
said that iran would neither hinder nor
support attempts to assassinate salman
rushdie but other groups iranian link
groups and other islamic groups continue
to put a bounty on his head and he's
really lived under the threat of that
there has been a three million dollar
bounty on his head issued by other
extremist groups so he's lived with that
threat come out of hiding
and managed to lead a fair fairly normal
life but he's always had this threat of
muslim extremists uh plotting uh to
attack him because of the anger about
that book
and it seems that something has happened
today that may either have been inspired
by that book or there could be some
other
motivation for the attack but certainly
it seems he has been attacked in chat
chat
in upstate new york but as i say we
don't know the nature of the attack
whether he was punched or stabbed and we
don't seem to know exactly what
condition he's in okay thank you so much
dominic uh dominic wagner international
affairs editor in washington dc